mike can we just say one thing now about
washington
i mean
what is this franchise doing
jay gruden after the game standing
solidly behind case keenum with his five
turnovers yesterday and his first round
pick on the bench and look we're not
there every day and chris would be a
great person to ask you know to to
discuss this we're not there every day
but how possibly
with such a depressing
you know
gut-crunching awful performance on
monday night do you say to your fan base
yep we're going up to the giants and
it's a battle of bad teams in the nfc
east and we're going to throw case
keenum at the giants boy i'll tell you
what that's going to inspire confidence
in your fan base and and you know so we
don't know
if this quarterback if dwayne haskins is
ready and i understand that but all i
know is that here's what i've seen out
of this team this offseason they got
into a squabble with their franchise
left tackle he's still not there and
what in the world are you holding on to
him for why didn't you cash that lottery
ticket in with houston on labor day
weekend no we are going to stand solid
and trent williams will come back they
look like fools
it's it's an utterly preposterous way to
run your organization and now you've got
your first round pick that you take and
he's not playing because for some reason
at 0-3 you want to stand behind case
keenum and his five turnover performance
i mean
this is a moribund franchise and i don't
know how those fans can be anything
but you know sort of destitute right now
i i you and listen it's hard for me to
argue against anything you said there i
mean you're right the redskins are a
mess there's nothing i can really say
you know the one thing i don't like
about it is that it gets blamed on jay
gruden i will defend him a little bit
because a lot of issues you just talked
about are not j gruden issues there are
other people within the organization
jay gruden's just the one that has to be
put there out on tv with his face on the
screen looking like he's responsible for
everything that's going on there you
know i think with the quarterback
situation we're very close to dwayne
haskins time uh he he is raw we saw that
in the preseason you know leading into
last night case keenum had played good
football he had given them opportunities
i mean it was five touchdowns zeros
interceptions the first two weeks last
night was a disaster there's no doubt he
threw some dumb interceptions he had
some bad pocket presents you know but
again they're another team i i checked
the rule book they're allowed to run the
ball with some success too they can't do
anything so they were over matched and i
think that jay gruden is trying to show
a little loyalty to case keenum after
the game but
i don't know if that'll happen today
once they watch back the film and maybe
daniel snyder and some other people get
involved in the conversation to go what
are we doing to peter's point what are
we doing we're all in three we're not
going to the super bowl let's start the
new era let's start it this week against
that crappy giants defense and see if
dwayne haskins can't get out there and
do something positive
and that's right it's a perfect time to
do it
you can reign on daniel jones parade go
ahead
yeah hey look but the one thing that
chris just said
that that i think is very very important
case keenum is only
a bridge to dwayne haskins yeah okay and
it's not it's not necessarily the george
washington bridge it's not a long bridge
you don't have to do it for 17 weeks
and it's shown now they're going nowhere
this year and unless dwayne haskins is
not ready to play
it's time to play dwayne haskins
yeah and look if you're gonna use the
15th overall pick in the draft on dwayne
haskins he'd better be ready to play
it's on the coaching staff to get him
ready to play and this may be that
tension that we see from time to time
where there's a head coach who knows the
clock is ticking on him and he'd rather
try to win as many games as he can so
he's willing to go with a guy that he
thinks giving gives him a better chance
to win even though it hasn't worked so
far
instead of rolling the dice on the
rookie but i think they're getting
closer to the point where they got to go
with haskins and you know booger
mcfarland last night peter was pointing
out uh and and you pick up you know some
of the things that the broadcasting crew
will glean from talking to people in the
organization as a prime time game
approaches i got the distinct impression
that booger mcfarland's under the belief
that the clock is ticking very loudly on
jay gruden and the switch to dwayne
haskins comes after gruden is gone
i mean that could be uh it's you know
look he now is
uh 15 below 500 in five and or in six
years you know he hasn't won a playoff
game it's amazing how long daniel snyder
has stayed with him and look
i like jay gruden and i think he is a
good football coach
but in the nfl you're paid to produce
results
and i'm not saying that any good would
come of firing him and i'm not even
suggesting that they should fire him all
i'm saying is that you know this is a
franchise that is totally messed up
right now we're only three games into
the season and i don't know that there's
any franchise in the nfl
that can be
less optimistic right now
than washington is
as our good friend big cat says
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things whether it's using the wrong
quarterback stirring the gatorade with a
sleeve of cups still wrapped in plastic
or spelling london fletcher's name wrong
on the jumbotron last night they did
that what they
spelled london fletcher's name wrong yes
they did he's wrong hey at least they
didn't call him kurt right
uh
f-l-e
what they spell it t-h-a-r
oh my gosh was it mike
it was it was uh the t and the c were
were flipped uh but that's okay it was
only on the giant jumbotron for
thousands to see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports